mangroves are some of the most diverse
habitats on the planet
these Coastal forests which have adapted
to living constantly changing salt water
tides are home to sharks manatees and
tigers
but people depend on mangroves too
much
foreign
[Music]
so far the protection offered to coastal
areas hasn't been enough of an incentive
to save this precious ecosystem
[Laughter]
is
in the decade after 2020 the area of
mangroves decreased by over 1 million
hectares globally
this is especially troubling in West
Africa where 80 of the population live
on the Atlantic coast
temperatures
they quote
rising sea levels have caused widespread
erosion and flooding in low-lying areas
while Rising temperatures and drought
accelerate the evaporation of water and
increase salinity killing off mangroves
foreign
Senegal has been hit particularly hard
losing a third of its mangrove forest
between 1950 and the early 2000s
in a village at the mouth of the Senegal
River 1500 people have already been
moved Inland to makeshift camps
authorities have warned that at least 15
000 people are at risk of being
displaced as rising sea levels flood
homes mosques and agricultural land
in a village called jiffer inhabitants
have already seen most of their mangrove
forest disappear while the coast
continues to erode
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
such as rolling giant Boulders into the
sea to act as barriers against the
rising sea levels
foreign
come on
some communities are taking other action
too and replanting their lost Mangrove
forests
they could store up to seven times more
carbon than terrestrial forests reducing
climate change and protecting Villages
from Coastal erosion and flooding
they could also offer residents greater
economic benefits than they've ever had
before
foreign
ecosystem
mangroves are food factories
The Roots provide a surface that oysters
and other mollusks can colonize and grow
on and the complex structure of
Meandering channels offers a sanctuary
to many different kinds of fish
ecosystem
for centuries in villages like dasilame
people had relied on the mangroves to
harvest oysters and other Seafood
as the forest disappeared so too did
this way of life
[Music]
but following a grant from the United
Nations the community have been able to
replant their forests and begin farming
again
foreign
[Music]
slowly but surely the forests have grown
back and the community also made other
changes to make sure both mangroves and
oysters would thriveland
the workers put Stakes with thin ropes
in the mud for the oysters to latch onto
this reduces pressure on the remaining
mangroves and lets the oysters grow
bigger
farmers can now sell fresh oysters to
local Seaside Resorts or can them for a
much higher profit than they ever could
before
utilization
foreign
all around the young mangroves the
villagers have seen the return of fish
crabs and other species that had
disappeared
it's something that could be replicated
all over the world as a tool to help
communities while Global efforts are
made to fight climate change
is
foreign